bonjour bienvenue dans sa zone
kadi avec ce matin notre invité sylviane
marché bonjour je vends bertrand qu'un
riche
merci d'être présente dans ce studio
s'il ya de l'archer jeune universitaire
martiniquaise vous rayonner à
l'international
vous êtes chargé de recherche au cnrs on
le dit vous êtes politologue et
philosophe et vous êtes donc chargé de
recherche au cnrs en sciences politiques
vous êtes actuellement en poste à
l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales
1 vous êtes précisément chercheuse à
l'institut de recherche
interdisciplinaire sur les enjeux
sociaux l'iris et on ajoutera que vous
êtes spécialiste notamment en études
coloniales et postcoloniales et vous
êtes de passage dans votre pays natal
vous avez voulu échapper pendant
quelques temps au confinement dans
l'hexagone c'est bien ça c'est bien
marché c'est bien ça je reconnais que la
situation sanitaire en france était
assez pesante et puis je reconnais que
je n'aime pas beaucoup l'hiver donc
retrouver la famille et puis surtout
pouvoir travailler dans un cadre propice
à la concentration à la détente était
l'occasion que j'ai saisie voilà alors
on va évoquer pendant quelques minutes
vos actualités quelques projets
également que vous avez on précisera
aussi que après avoir enseigné un temps
à alex eu âgées vous avez également
professeur à l'université de new york et
vous terminez actuellement une enquête
sur la fraude au féminisme
particulièrement en ile de france dans
la grande région parisienne on évoquera
sa bien sûr et puis vous donc vous
terminez cette enquête de sociologie
politique
et puis vous observez également ce qui
se passe en martinique puisque vous avez
eu l'occasion va commencer par la ce ce
confinement également en martinique on
l'a entendu on y est dans l'actualité
troisième restrictions de dépenses de
restrictions de déplacements
et puis également depuis quelques temps
un réveil de l'opinion publique par
rapport à un certain nombre de sujets
notamment sur le dossier du traitement
judiciaire de l'usaj de illégal de
chlordécone et puis également la cette
quête d'identité et les luttes
féministes aussi qui qui réapparaissent
parce qu'il en a eu
quel regard vous poser un petit peu sur
cette évolution je dirais sociologique
et politique de notre pays
bon j observe que deux choses pour ce
qui concerne la classe politique jeu
puisque nous sommes à la veille d'une
échéance électorale
j'ai l'impression d'une espèce de
d'épuisement du discours politique
d'atomisation de 2,2 de la parole
politique autour de questions
étroitement gestionnaire institutionnel
on va dire formaliste ou procédurale
d'un côté et de l'autre côté des
reformulations du politique par
différents groupes notamment les dix
activistes du rbn mais pas seulement
les initiatives des martiniquais autour
de la question de l'environnement de
l'écologie
j'ai participé donc parce que en train
d'avouer à certaines personnes que je
suis là depuis un moment j'étais
présente dans la rue le 27 février
donc tout ça me fait voir que il ya une
espèce de de décalage entre une
préoccupation de la classe politique
pour des enjeux étroitement technicien
politiciens et de l'autre une aspiration
j'ai l'impression de la population
martiniquaise a une vision à une vision
du commun à une vision d'un horizon
politique commun vision à que ne
proposent pas me semble-t-il la classe
politique et qui se dissémine un peu
partout dans diverses initiatives alors
certaines conflictuelle d'autres plus
organisés plus structuré du coup j'ai
l'impression que la martinique comme
toutes les sociétés bouge au sens où
nous sommes affectés par ce qui se passe
à l'extérieur nous cherchons aussi à
produire nos propres définitions de vers
quoi nous voulons aller mais là la
clarification de cette visée elle est
pas très très claires j'ai l'impression
alors si tu as de l'argent on en vient à
ce travail que vous menez que vous êtes
en train de terminer cette enquête de
sociologie politique sur l'affront fait
ministre en france un à partir aussi des
expériences de l'afro féminisme aux
états unis que vous connaissez bien
aussi alors parlez nous un petit peu de
ce travail de recherche est une chose
l'enquète que je mène s'inscrit pas dans
un dialogue direct avec ce qu'on appelle
dans la littérature scientifique le
black feminism même si c'est des choses
que j'ai lues
je suis pas spécialiste des états unis
par contre ce qui m'intéresse on
pourrait dire c'est le fil conducteur de
mon travail et qui explique aussi
pourquoi je m'intéresse à des questions
sociales et politiques qui se posent
dans l'hexagone c'est la question du
lien entre émancipation et
subjectivation dans des sociétés
travaillé par le passé colonial
donc j'ai d'abord travaillé dans le cas
de la thèse sur la question de la
citoyenneté après l'abolition d'esclaves
sur cette question on peut dire et je la
reprends ce dans un autre cadre à
travers une réflexion sur des jeunes
femmes en france
fille d'immigrés subsahariens africains
et filles d'antillais réunionnais et
guyanais installé en ile de france et ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de comprendre
pourquoi une mobilisation politique
féministe d'une génération à ces jeunes
elles ont entre 25 et 30 ans elles sont
nées dans l'hexagone elles se
définissent comme femme noire anti
raciste anti sexistes du coup elles sont
au croisement entre la sphère des
mobilisations anti racistes les
mobilisations féministes mais aussi les
mobilisations sociales et moi ce qui
m'intéresse de comprendre pourquoi dans
la société française d'aidé sujet placé
à la marge
en tout cas des acteurs sociaux placé à
la marche construisent des formes de
subjectivation politiques plus ou moins
compliquées et contrariées par des
conditions sociales et en même temps
inséparable du passé de leurs parents et
en l'occurrence les migrations parce que
l'eau niall dans l'hexagone alors c'est
une question qui est un peu sensible
presque polémiques parfois on l'a vu
dernièrement avec que la réponse par
exemple de la candidate aux élections
régionales en île de france
l'ancien journal vous avez suivi serré
il va oui oui les régulations il a
évoqué les mixités voit la non mixité ou
voilà qu'est ce que vous en pensez où
elle a dit bon des personnes de
carnation blanc peuvent venir écouter
mais bon peut-être qu'elles pourront pas
s'exprimer
cynthia sion n'a pas tout de suite think
vient d'avoir écouté alors c'est une
question intéressante
deux choses la pratique de réunions non
mixtes n'est pas nouvelle elle existe
dans l'histoire des féminismes en france
je vais dire les féminismes au pluriel
elle a existé dans alors elle n'était
pas formulée comme ça en tout cas dans
l'histoire des féminismes c'était
clairement dit comme ça c'est à dire
c'étaient des espaces fermés aux hommes
mais qu'il se définissait d'abord comme
des espaces des femmes
cette question a été réinvesti en tout
cas ce mode de politisation a été
réinvesti par d'autres mouvements
féministes hors de france
en l'occurrence de femmes afro
américaine mais aussi latina et c est ce
type de mode d'organisation qu'il faut
bien comprendre comme étant un temps un
temps c'est-à-dire un moment ça n'est
pas un levier du ne sais pas le levier
d'une organisation sociale à l'échelle
de la société qui est proposée par qui
serait proposée par des militants tout
en l'occurrence il s'agissait de l'unef
ce sont des espaces d'entre eux soit
dans lesquelles les gens fassent par
lequel il faut aussi que c'est ce que
des militants et en l'occurrence des
militantes
alors je vais être très franche avec
vous j'ai participé à des ateliers comme
cela en tant que sociologue
donc j'ai participé à des ateliers en
non mixité avec des militantes seins
frau féministes qui clairement m'ont
acceptée par miel en tant
qu'observatrice parce que je suis
sociologue femme et noire ce qui est ce
qu'il faut comprendre ce sont des
espaces dans lesquels les gens
produisent du collectif à travers le
partage d'expériences individuelles de
racialisation de discrimination avec des
enjeux parfois psychologique assez fort
et de ces moments là où chacun se
raconte dans une dimension presque
thérapeutique ce chacun qui se raconte
renvoie à l'ensemble des personnes
présentes
une expérience qui est partagée donc une
expérience collective et à la lumière de
cette réflexivité construite ensemble
les gens évoquent des pistes de
résistance d'adaptation dans les cas de
mouvements féministes d'organisation
pour pour construire un discours
politique comprend bien ce que ça peut
donner comme forme de catharsis si vous
voulez vous exprimer
mais sur la forme est ce que ça ne peut
pas donner parfois l'impression d' une
racialisation voire même d'un racisme à
rebours quoi
voyez ce que je veux dire j'aime bien
aussi j'attends j'attends en finale de
compte aussi quand j'entends ce que vous
dites
s'agit-il de réunions qui exclut des
personnes quand en l'occurrence on a des
en général les gens qui décident
d'organiser ce type des réunions sont
des positions sont des personnes
généralement qui finalement qui se
définissent comme des victimes le choix
de ce temps de l'art en de lentes reçoit
est aussi un choix de confrontation avec
sa position de victime dans un but qui
est celui de sortir de la position de
victime donc ce que je veux dire par là
il ne s'adresse pas un alter en auquel
on dit tu ne viens pas par contre
l'effet induit c'est la non présence de
ceux qui sont considérés comme
appartenant l'occurrence au groupe
majoritaire ou opposition aux personnes
en position de pouvoir si on déplace le
raisonnement qui est qui leur est opposé
à l'échelle de la société
tous les jours nous avons des espaces
d'entre eux soient masculins de pouvoir
dans we catégorisé comme blanc qui ne
pose pas de problème et je voudrais
souligner quand même quelque chose c'est
que ce qui dérange fondamentalement
finalement dans ce type de stratégie
politique
c'est l'enjeu politique qui est
clairement posée par les acteurs je vais
prendre un exemple trivial quand les
antillais et guyanais s'organise en
france hexagonale pour organiser des
associations allée type boudin accra
c'est de l'entre- soit c'est de la non
mixité ça ne dérange personne
parce qu'il n'ya pas de finalité
politique derrière c'est à dire d'une
critique de l'organisation sociale d'une
critique des discriminations d'une
critique finalement des inégalités et de
leurs sous bassement
racialise ans dont on voit bien que la
question est ce que c'est je veux
souligner c'est le retournement du
discours qui consiste à dire c'est du
racisme anti blanc c'est aussi une
manière de mettre sous le tapis
un problème que ces actrices font voir
et là par contre il faut comprendre
qu'on assiste en france à une nouvelle
forme de construction des mobilisations
sociales antiracistes et féministe c'est
à dire on n'est plus dans sos racisme
organiser des barbecues et des concerts
mais politiser la question du lien
social dans ses ramifications devient
d'autant plus sensible exactement à
devoir aller pour conclure déjà oui s'il
ya le marché on va terminer donc sur
quelques projets que vous avez alors
vous allez passer la prochaine année
universitaire à aux états unis oui à
l'université harvard pour préparer
justement un prochain livre votre
prochain livre qui va porter sur la pro
féminine exactement or quelques bruits
rapidement ben je vais passer un an
l'année universitaire aux états chine
sont à la portée d'un septembre on sait
exactement qui est un centre prestigieux
aux états unis consacré aux questions de
lait des études diasporique et
africaines américaines et là je vais
passer une année de résidence d'écriture
si vous voulez pour écrire cet ouvrage
sur la frau féminisme qui paraîtra
vraisemblablement ce jour en france ou
sur le viol enquête en fait sur
l'encaissé cette enquête que je termine
qui va paraître aux éditions du seuil en
janvier 2023 si je me débrouille bien et
si je respecte le calendrier de
l'éditeur voilà donc cette enquête
sociologique sera publié sous forme de
livre vous partez aux états unis pour
préparer ça vous avez d'autres projets
en cours deux ouvrages à paraître
toujours aux éditions du seuil et aux
éditions la découverte la soirée hommage
collectif 1 sur l'histoire des
esclavages soir dans l'histoire mondiale
d esclavage j'ai une contribution dans
ce livre et puis un livre en septembre
qui sort à la découverte histoire
globale et transnationale de la france
j écris avec deux collègues un chapitre
sur la république dans une perspective
critique
donc je parlerai de toussaint louverture
de dessalines des luttes anticoloniales
de personnes comme aimé césaire ou
s'engorge
dans le chapitre voit la cdc en cours
ainsi son courtier déjà écrit on le voit
vous travaillez beaucoup
sylviane marché c'est ben c'est tout le
mal qu'on vous souhaite aussi merci je
me reposais ce qui explique aussi que je
choisis le temps ou que je consacre à
l'écriture est aussi au retrait donc ce
qui fait que je je reconnais que je suis
pas souvent disponible je m'en excuse
auprès des gens qui parfois me
sollicitent
mais on peut pas tout faire il faut
faire des choix le coût n'a qu'une vie
on signale également la reddition oui
n'importe quel autre citoyen à la
rentrée en septembre aux éditions du
seuil également l'autre citoyen l'idéal
républicain et les antilles est
l'esclave votre premier ouvrage qui
étaient parmi les qualités l'occasion
d'un autre
voilà voilà des années en 2015 donc
c'est réédition en format poche
merci d'avoir répondu à nos nations
bonne suite et bon séjour bon travail au
général à partir du mois de septembre
bon week-end à toutes et à tous bon
courage